I'm not going to do a few classic
problems that show up a lot at math
competitions and sometimes on
standardized tests and they seem like
very daunting and intimidating problems
but hopefully over the course of this
video you'll realize that if you kind of
see what they're asking for it's really
not that bad so let's try this first one
right over here they tell us a plus B
plus C is equal to 7 and then they ask
us what is 5 a plus 5b plus 5c equal 2
and the first reaction is like well they
just gave me one equation right over
here one equation with three unknowns
how do I solve for a B or C you don't
have to be able to solve for a B or C in
order to figure out what 5a plus 5b plus
5c is so I'll let you think about that
for a second
so the big idea here is to realize that
5a plus 5b plus 5c that's just the same
thing as five times a plus B plus C if
you distribute the 5 here 5 times a 5
times B 5 times C you get 5a plus 5b
plus 5c another way you could think of
it is we are factoring a 5 out if you
factor a 5 out you're left with 5 times
a plus B plus C now how do we evaluate
this well that first that first equation
gave us all the information that we
needed they told us that a plus B plus C
is equal to 7 a plus B plus C is equal
to 7 so 5 times a plus B plus C is the
same exact thing and I think you see
where this is going now is 5 times 5
times 7 and now this becomes pretty
straightforward that's going to be equal
to 35 let's do one more of these and
this is going to be a little bit more
involved but hopefully you see the same
idea so we're told a plus B plus C is
equal to negative one and we have two
more variables here we're told that X
plus y is equal to seven and then they
asked us this big hairy thing what is
this equal to and I'll give you a few
seconds to give it give a little bit of
thought well you could imagine you've
given three variables with one equation
up here and
our two variables with another equation
we have five unknowns with two equations
there's no way we're going to be able to
individually figure out what a or B or C
or X or Y is but maybe we can use what
we saw in the last example to solve this
and so we might want to do is rearrange
it so that we have the X's and Y's kind
of group kind of grouped together and
the A's B's and C's kind of group
together so let's try that out so let's
focus first on the A's B's and C's so we
have negative 9 a negative 9 B I'll go
and order alphabetical order negative 9
B and we have negative 9 C and I think
you see what's emerging negative 9 C and
then let's work on the x's and the Y's
and then we have negative 7x minus 7x
and then we have a minus 7y so minus 7y
so all I have done is rearranged this
expression here but this makes it in a
way or it makes it a little bit clearer
of what's going on here this these first
3 terms these first three terms I can
factor out a negative 9 and I get
negative 9 times a plus B plus C and
these second two terms I can factor out
a 7 minus 7 times X plus y and just to
verify if you wanted to go the other way
multiply this negative 7 times X plus y
you'll get this multiply a negative 9
times a plus B plus C distribute it
you'll get this right over here and so
this makes it a little bit clearer what
is a plus B plus C equal to well they
tell us right over here a plus B plus C
is equal to negative 1 this whole
expression is negative 1 this and at
least in the parentheses and what is X
plus y equal to let me do this in a new
color what is X plus y equal 2 well they
tell us right over here X plus y is
equal is equal to 7 so this whole thing
simplifies to negative 9 times negative
1 times negative 1 minus 7 minus 7 times
7 times 7 and so this is equal to or the
homestretch negative 9 times negative 1
well that's positive 9
and then negative seven times seven is
negative 49 so it's 9 minus 49 which is
equal to negative 40 and we are done